as
al ritmo de la música de la capoeira a
la ciudad de río de janeiro protesta
contra el asesinato de un joven
refugiado al congoleño de 24 años
estrella de la violencia de su país hace
8 años y que encontró la muerte en la
playa de barra uno de los lugares más
ricos de la ciudad sólo porque estaba
pidiendo que le pagasen dos días de
trabajo 200 reales lo que equivale a 37
dólares
[Aplausos]
m
gracias a todos ustedes gracias por el
amor que están demostrando por móvil
solo queremos pedir justicia hasta el
final hasta el final
y felizmente un hombre
lamentablemente en brasil existe un
racismo estructural el racismo que
nosotros como pueblo negro
experimentamos todos los días con miedo
de morir de salir de casa y no volver a
casa
estamos viviendo el momento del triste
esta ciudad no merecía estar en las
noticias por causa de tanta violencia
ella siempre fue un lugar de alegría y
acogían de alegría y de alimento
no
viento de río de janeiro anunciado hoy
que transformará este kiosco donde el
monte fue brutalmente asesinado en un
memorial dedicado a la cultura congoleña
y africana además van a ofrecer la
gestión del kiosco a sus familiares como
forma de compensación por la pérdida de
su familiar queridos